Ray Stevenson was no stranger to the
Marvel Universe when he joined the cast
of 2011's Thor having previously
appeared as Frank Castle also known as
The Punisher in the 2008 film Punisher
war zone over the years Stenson was also
notable for appearances in films like
Kill the Irishman and R as well as
television series like Dexter black saes
and Star Wars Rebels however in 2011 he
made his Marvel Cinematic Universe debut
as volag and as guardian Warrior who
helps rescue Thor from Earth after his
banishment by Odin Stevens Su repris a
role in Thor the Dark World and Thor
Ragnarok where he's killed by Hela
during her conquest of Asgard at the
beginning of the film The actor died in
May 2023 after a sudden hospitalization
of filming in Italy for fans of the
actor's work he made a postumus
appearance in the Disney plus Star Wars
series Ahsoka